el tribunal constitucional de perú
concedió un habeas corpus al ex
presidente alberto fujimori estable
restituye el indulto otorgado por el ex
presidente pedro pablo kuczynski en el
año 2017 fujimori venía cumpliendo una
condena de 25 años por los casos de la
cantuta y barrios altos con la sentencia
del tribunal constitucional le
corresponde a la corte suprema trasladar
el fallo al instituto penitenciario para
la liberación de alberto fujimori que se
podría ejecutar en las próximas horas
para algunos juristas la sentencia del
tribunal constitucional no corresponde
porque la corte interamericana de
derechos humanos señala que los crímenes
de lesa humanidad deben ser investigados
juzgados y sancionados y se destaca que
no se le puede aplicar ningún tipo de
indulto amnistía ni perdón en este
sentido expertos locales afirman que la
liberación de alberto fujimori puede ser
anulado por la corte interamericana de
derechos humanos por el lado del
fujimorismo exigen que se respete el
fallo porque manifiestan que fujimori no
fue procesado por un delito de lesa
humanidad y su condena es de homicidio
calificado en la calidad de autor
mediato en las próximas horas vamos a
ver qué reacciones se van a registrar
mientras tanto algunos simpatizantes de
fujimori están rodeando clínica donde
venía siendo atendido así como el lugar
donde ha venido purgando prisión todos
estos años por otra parte los deudos y
familiares de los casos conocidos como
la cantuta y barrios altos señalan que
van a apelar a los tribunales
internacionales para que puedan obtener
justicia finalmente